- That is the worst analogy ever!
- Oh no, it's so good.
(rock music)
- Basically, we're gonna try food,
and guess whether it's instant or fresh.
- I love instant food, 'cause it's
so easy to make, and it's so quick.
You're the opposite.
- Yeah, I'm the opposite.
I cook almost every night.
- Recently we've been on a diet,
and we've been eating more fresh things,
and so now I feel like we'll be able to
distinguish what is
instant, and what is fresh.
- I'm actually very excited about this.
- Mm mm.
- Because so many people
hate on instant food.
- I feel like that's not how food's
supposed to come, at all.
(rock music)
- This consistency feels
consistent throughout.
- Yeah, this looks like
it has its makeup on,
its foundation, it's
ready to strike a pose.
This one looks like it
just came from the farm,
it doesn't care, it
doesn't have its makeup on.
- This one looks like a potato.
- This is nice.
- That's tasty.
For the record, instant
food can taste good...
- Don't backtrack.
- Doesn't mean you should eat it.
- Just do your test.
- That's homemade.
- Yeah, this one's instant.
- Instant.
- And this one--
- Mm hmm. Yes, yes.
- is fresh.
- This one is instant.
(ding)
(rock music)
- Powdered eggs?
- Wait what?
(gunshot)
- Oh!
- You can't really tell.
- Delicious.
- Also delicious.
- I would eat both.
- No, I would eat this.
- Fresh, instant.
- Agreed.
- I think these are real.
- I'm gonna go with this is the real.
- My guess is opposite to him,
but I think they both taste good.
(ding)
- It's probably more
effort to make powdered egg
than like a real
scrambled egg, cause you--
- Just put a egg!
- Yeah, you just cook it.
- I already know.
- I already know!
- Yeah!
- I used to eat instant mac and cheese
all the time in college.
- Right off the bat, I
think because of the color,
- Yeah.
- That this one is probably the fake one,
but I think that the
instant one is yummier.
- It looks like it has
meltier cheese on it,
like cheesy cheese.
- This clearly has more
love, 'cause there's
like, seasoning on it.
- (laughs) Yes it does!
This one's like, "mmmph."
- (laughs)
- This is where I'm gonna eat my words,
this has to be something
like Kraft or something.
- Yeah.
- That was my jam growing up,
my brother and I used to
fight over the last bowl.
- And this is like, some real cheese shit.
Look at that.
You know it's real when the
cheese is stuck together.
- This is better, though. It just is.
- You just said how much
you like grew up on this,
something, and something
with your brother...
- Can you not do that with this one?
- Mira.
- Yes you can.
- No you can't.
(laughing)
- This is instant for sure.
- Real food isn't usually,
like, that bright in color.
- This is from a box.
(ding)
- Oh! Oh.
- So they're two different
types of noodles, so it's hard.
You made it hard on me.
- Okay.
- Whoa.
- Mmm.
- Can I smell this one again?
(laughing)
- They're both really good.
- See how the noodle is folding weirdly?
Which means that it's probably instant.
- Here, I'm just gonna
use my psychic abilities.
- Wait.
- I'm just gonna go with YB on this.
- I'm gonna go with the
white noodles as instant.
- Great.
- I think this is instant.
- Wait. Let me try this one again.
- You have five seconds.
Five, four,
three, two.
(funk music)
- Coin in the potatoes, baby!
- This was my original answer, though.
- No, it wasn't.
- Yes, it was.
- I love instant food.
I think it's great. I think it's genius.
You don't have to worry
about it perishing.
- The food won't perish, but you might.
- It's a good balance
to have fresh food, too.
- No matter if we're on a diet or not,
we still know our food.
I do wanna finish that
mac n cheese, though.
- [Curly] I do wanna finish those noodles.
(funk music)